look at him he's running up the hall
he's looking a lot better than Colin
Quinn was coming up the hall the other
day it's not hard to look better Colin
coming up that hole nicked Apollo come
on in man nor eggs eggs no farts this is
just a fart is earlier hours ago this is
eggs more than hours ago yeah exactly we
were just saying like you sprinting up
the hall you looked a lot better than
Colin Quinn you know that was coming
went up just stumbling up the other day
the only killer she's gonna get up there
we can't hide that no more huh what's
going on man thanks for having me Jesus
Christ we eat eggs and avocado smells
like eggs and [ __ ] which by the way
thank you so is it where's the buttons
on these thing okay welcome to the show
my friend fellas how are you guys sound
great I was listening on the way in
thank you thank you thank you I left my
house at 7:15 just got here okay so you
can stick this up your sister's ass yeah
I had a long one this morning to it I'm
in the city it was a [ __ ] it was
terrible usually what it was it took me
like talking about sorry if I don't show
any sympathy for you but I'm coming from
Albany for Christ's sake on a bike
you take the metro-north though you
don't Isis takes the metro no okay
I'm scared [ __ ] of trains because of
that but really but that's the thing I
live equidistant between like chapter 20
nation and on student kinda but by the
time I Drive over there it's like five
miles everybody's already parked yeah
it's a [ __ ] by the time we do all that
[ __ ] you know I can be stuck in traffic
in a sawmill so what you're standing on
the train because all those [ __ ]
people are lining up to get in it's the
[ __ ] worse I felt like you know I
felt like Charlie Sheen in Wall Street
like I felt like I'm at other times I'm
going that you know I'm in the [ __ ]
elevator with any other package it's the
worst
hour and I'm only 34 miles it takes an
hour and 25 minutes when I go home today
it'll take me literally 46 47 minutes
right it's [ __ ] all like it's like
when you're at a wedding and they do
that train dance it's a long line of
cars from here to where I live right
[ __ ] it it doesn't work anymore
it's a nightmare Bobby Kelly moved up
there he's not nearly as far as your mom
another yeah I'm another like
12 miles north of Bobby so you know like
I said six minutes from Buffalo good
career move
yeah the place up there mrs. Nick places
amazing well I've asked you up eight
times Jimmy I'm up we can get some
[ __ ] they boys coming out of the place
it's nice I was listening to you I was
crying when I get there gonna choke them
yeah they kill everyone if they were
both career politicians I would agree
with you right so I saw the judge
trumpet occur when it comes to debating
say this is my podcast forever yeah if
you know first of all the whole
narrative is bullsh is gonna come down
to the debates I was saying eight months
ago that's the case he's [ __ ] right
cuz she's gonna look better debating
she's been doing it all I'm not dating
yeah uh so and that's the key lying to a
good debate so I judge him on a curve
right you know I thought he did fine in
this hole and I'm with you the whole
blow-up about oh my god he's not going
to accept that why he for months he's
been saying it's rigged it would look
silly if he was all accepted exactly
Chris Wallace would go well why would
you accept it if you're saying it's
right he answered that right G Chris
Wallace was good he was really he was
good right yeah
I mean he kept some trouble employment
sure some stock yeah I know I thought he
I thought he was a really good he's one
of those anal guys and but yeah can you
explain this to me both ears please yeah
what is the point of having a live
audience if they can't make a [ __ ]
peep why not just do it in a pseudo
studio like this I never understood the
live audience at all I sent in Town Hall
format is stupid
well bet they get to interact hi guys
here I can bone her yes he's a big
Trayvon Martin fan I um but you know I'm
saying yeah I was getting pissed every
time right somebody would get a little
giggle and he was like an old school mom
hey hey man what do I have a live
audience yeah that's a good point why
did you watch him before the debate like
right when he first got out there what
did he do he really reprimanded them
about not talking and talked about how
important it was for America that they
don't talk your gather like he spent
minutes yes going over why they should
not talk yeah he said their visitors
visitors yeah you're not part of this
debate your visitors over you [ __ ]
you why is there an audience if they
can't like you but because they do laugh
in a wild I'm saying and they don't want
that because Trump would Maul her if
that was the case he's not going to
stand up oh god his prep probably came
from the DNC we can't have any laughter
or I don't know I don't understand that
I mean she had a good line she had a
really couple yes she had a specialist
they were talking on the Trump towels
and she goes built by Chinese steel that
was great [ __ ] belly laughing yeah
you know for that thick ankle dogface
with no sense of humor you know when
there is creepy man but that is I mean
that tells you what we were talking
about about and I guess if you want to
look at Twitter's the American public
but then all you don't think because
that's what's trending after the debate
was hashtag Chinese steel and hashtag
nasty woman like it was just whoever got
the funniest line yeah and then there's
a bit you know I'm starting to [ __ ]
megyn kelly stone and get on my nerves
yeah she's probably though I know I like
that face yeah glad she go to the David
Bowie looking back to being a what'd she
do
well mama she had the hair back for
about six months oh yeah yes this is
type of talk feminist love her goal
value is her [ __ ] hairdo why are they
talking about Bill O'Reilly hairstyle
these guys go Riley got a lot of [ __ ]
down there Levittown yeah talk a lot
about Bill O'Reilly and his loofah
sponge
well that went away but she you know oh
why why look at that that was that's
megyn kelly that's her that's her on air
on the Kelly fine right there
that's megyn kelly it is her yeah she
did it you get a magazine spread yeah
yeah GQ but she's my gams what what I
know why do you have why you have to say
nasty woman cuz a woman's [ __ ] nasty
yeah you you can't have it both ways
feminists if you want to play in the big
leagues right you can't go you know
wherever were equal to men we do
anything you can do
oh we called her nasty which by the way
wrong if Hillary had said he's an awful
man it's not like anybody would have
been like what'd she call him a man yeah
oh yeah I mean can we get to the
Equality is this what you want right we
asked Larry often you play rough nasty
woman it's fine she's so hot she's not
even a woman that was a sapota friend to
me I know I'd pork her well
I'm more of a Greta Van Susteren fan
from one side yeah she has a whole
spread Greta - oh wow she could get them
to do this she's in a male football
league she's in uh oh god I never saw
those I've been wasting my my come on
Greta that's not a shop
oh Jesus Christ yeah yeah dick that's
not even her yeah it's another blonde
but there you go she's married with kids
all right yeah but doesn't matter yeah
um you think Ron I'm being filmed this
is the thing today man I know yeah you
got it
roger ailes was sexually harassing Greta
Van Susteren how about was that the
funniest thing when when they were
coming out like and say they were
sexually harassed Greta Cosby never get
anything I mean yeah okay yeah he ghetto
well she didn't molest at Fox the 72
year old Janet Jose met the best yeah
Greta so humiliated she goes Roger never
sexually harass anybody no Greta
he never sexually harassed you fist bump
me wanted a Christmas party it's like
the kid that the ugly kitty didn't get
molested by the preseason funded yeah
yeah no I think the priest was fine no
it was you see yet but yeah so I'm
getting a little sick of it it seems
like since ales had left it's already
changing a little the chicks are all
with a chest puffed up were you happy
that hillary was able to kind of duck
and weave around all the WikiLeaks
questions in a perfect world every
question would have been about that
right seriously we are so corrupt and
even if she wins which he probably will
it to me uh looks like the script was
written two years ago but even if she
went it's gonna be fun cuz though that
shit's gonna keep coming it's got to
it's got a kids come cuz that's the army
that Donald Trump created nobody's going
anywhere they're not leaving that's a
good point that's the thing like they
were still gonna be there after this
election yeah they're all still going to
be like fine you want to be President
well for the next four years
we're gonna make your life a living hell
no exactly you know you just watch I
mean the other did they dump though
every time they dump those WikiLeaks
then CNN would put something out about
Trump the New York Times it's so
orchestrated now if you just read into
it a little bit you don't even really
have know you know it by osmosis right
it's plainly obvious like when this
WikiLeaks thing started same time the
[ __ ] tape came out
yeah you know yeah and then Fox does one
thing and they're like oh look at that
bias there right if you need to watch
[ __ ] you wouldn't know anything about
[ __ ] WikiLeaks that's true
CNN Chris Cuomo goes you have to by the
way looking at WikiLeaks files is
illegal you have to get this from us
here and save it on the [ __ ] air no
no is that what he says because you have
to go through us
let's hope it's [ __ ] illegal at all
and then another chick on CNN Brooke
poor Brooke whatever Baldwin she didn't
understand term limits they talk about
term limits for congressmen she goes um
excuse me don't they already have term
limits and the saw the woman had a
letter down gently like no they you can
keep get elected you have to run yeah
but you know they have a president
that's what Dana Bash said but it was
fun tried this is a this is a woman on
CNN filled her in on how our government
works again yeah here oh look
he says here oh yeah so interesting
remember it's illegal to possess ah
these stolen documents it's different
for the media so everything you learn
about this you're learning from us oh
that's reassuring don't go to the
internet for anything the television
television eyes I'm playing cuts on my
show today of the Vicodin be talking
about they're interviewing some some
congressman from New York Republican and
he starts to he's talked and then he
starts to bring up the WikiLeaks Hillary
they owe his feed went off oh it's the
worst acting you've ever seen Chrissy
it's the same guy Chris comma goes oh we
lost him that sucks so I go arming I go
to Google more they have a compilation
tape of CNN doing that it really is like
five clips which brings up something bad
about Hillary here it is uh listen to
the bad acting here by by uh you know
two-thirds or more of the public knows
that Hillary Clinton's a liar she can't
be trusted and now the two faces of
Hillary Clinton are coming out the fact
through WikiLeaks that she says one
thing and though all right let's see if
we can get congressman calling the back
obviously we just lost the satellite
feed that sucks
haven't seen acting like that since John
Ritter and they come back he changes the
question this is from you-know-who egg
Alex Joe he goes oh look no they speak
for 30 seconds in between and they come
back and no two minutes two minutes and
thirty doing a better job than I've ever
heard you do going after Hakeem Jeffries
about how emails are not a mistake they
were an intentional choice on a series
of choices by Clinton but please play to
advantage and make the case that you
think Trump has to make tonight say now
the question is different has nothing to
do with what we were talking I'm telling
you they are the world when I was 22 I
didn't even know about politics like oh
these people if I get what Jimmy what's
worse when you're flying all over the
country would you do I know if you take
Delta a lot and you pin in the dig in
and they have CNN blaring on every
screen I I don't watch any movies or TV
on a play I don't care how long not on
the plane in the terminal at the if all
right you can't get away from it yeah I
go in the men's room in a stall the
[ __ ] code of Munich CNN is worse I
mean sometimes the drill will help drown
out that sound but it's really fresh
that's a good question yes as me of
MSNBC's were I have more respect for
them I feel like this is where we stand
timeout hi in Atlanta Delta's based out
of Atlanta that's right Roger turn is
the Ted Turner yeah they have a CNN
that's ago CNN is kind of mean
portraying themselves is like okay you
got your Fox conservative where were the
middle we see liberal we give you the
other and my opinion did the [ __ ]
worse right but yes they're lying MSNBC
comes out and says we hate [ __ ]
anybody who's white heterosexual man
let's go normally right and now Fox goes
that's all we like that because there
are boom oh [ __ ] I always want to do
that to equivocate Fox and MSNBC it's
not [ __ ] fair I don't see any [ __ ]
conservatives on MSNBC unless they
[ __ ] oh you mean like the at like
the talking head people like the donuts
inside it's yeah yeah Fox that's why I
like Fox they do have comics on like
I've done almost nothing I did Joy Behar
show a couple times it was Rachel and me
too but they don't have Canadians on or
different points that that like at least
Fox you know you can go on there and
[ __ ] around and say whatever you want
I've taken the liberal point on that one
when Lena Dunham got in trouble for that
stupid tweet which the people said was
anti-american anti butterin but it
really wasn't right
and I had he had me on I was debating
this kid who did Hannity
yeah but I didn't take the okay Babbitt
yeah oh she's gorgeous
yeah she's lovely you like her I do yeah
I like her neck I don't remember her
neck oh it's it's gonna like a perfect
neck she's very bright but I just didn't
I didn't think she was right about that
so yeah I done that one I took the
liberal point I get a good story that -
they call me remember when let him and
made a joke as about a rod bang and
Palin's daughter you know it was the
young daughter right yes and so they
called me Fox and Friends and said would
you like to come on and they you know
they had a screen call first right and I
said yeah let him I was out a bar I
thought that was a cheesy too easy joke
blah blah blah blah you know but on the
way and I I'm thinking about it I'm
reading in the paper and I changed my
mind
I did I'm like Oh Palin's a tough woman
she can handle or you know I'm sure so
and so when I go on the couch with the
Brian Kilmeade ado see ya so I changed
my sort of my tone and they they were
all right with it yeah but what's her
name Greta Greta the one that's gone not
greta gretchen carlson oh yeah I come
off and Brian Kilmeade introduced me
Gretchen I put my hand out she looks
down gives me the most hateful [ __ ] and
goes around me it was I was so really I
got my face getting like warm I was so
humiliated
Wow but she was [ __ ] fuming that I
didn't you know take the company that is
she seen either she seen my stand-up
comedy sad drop but um Roger Ailes was
playing in the office one time I love
this guy with his dick I'm Ted let me
talk about Ailes I have the same taste
as he does except regret I don't know
how I don't know how she she must have
blown Roger Ailes and he must have a
huge dick it stretch your mouth 11 I
believe a lot of that you know like you
the heads of the network like the how do
you not well especially when you look at
Fox News it's like the hottest women on
cable yeah how do you not be freed me I
don't believe that any of these guys are
really not creepy well of course you
don't think it's CNN those pervert I
mean that's righties were known to be
the stiff ones so that you know we're
not into kinky [ __ ] which is also a like
it certainly is certainly is so would
you like any kinky
you stripe music and not not that not
like you don't like to [ __ ] but the you
know I've been married almost 20 years
so kink for me is fingering my wife
watching jeopardy
types of fishes 450 um no I do i well i
yeah when i was in college and that's
how I defend gay people all the time
when people get upset about gay marriage
perverted next thing I go the [ __ ] I was
trying to do in college by I mean
drilling a hole in my in my disk it at
my fraternity's wall I come home he's
drilling a hole because his room is next
to the bathroom and would have a party
is sure it was the girls bathroom so
they did a lot of guys in the closet
watching girls pee through a hole inside
and I helped them with a drill I got the
bit and so that's it I don't blame you
no absolutely pee through that hole you
would yeah yeah clapping ladies shoes
telltale turn around of ladies shoes
yeah we looked in there what do we see
like four girls from lowest in there 40
pounds always came in to our table that
was still enough but ya know I did but
you Jimmy nearing a leg buyer you know
you're like I'm in a big Lee yeah yeah
there's a lot there's big Lee's kinking
big Lee it sounds like big league to my
family I hear big Liam oh yeah I think
that that's all you're gonna hear I know
I know
Lee great convinced I'm convinced you
saying big Lee and then somebody pulled
him aside and said that's not a [ __ ]
word say big league if you're gonna say
anything big time it's like you know
it's just where he says it not that time
exactly but it's probably this is seem
very presidents was a big time it's
childish you couldn't have you couldn't
have been thoroughly thrilled when when
when Hillary called him a puppet and
then his big response was I'm not a
puppet you are but she kinda is I
thought it was kind of true but ya know
he doesn't have to do that no he doesn't
have but but you know what I were gonna
backed it up he could have said I'm not
a puppet you are here's why right and
then explain to the world why she's a
puppet but to just say no but what's my
point
Sam he's not a professional politician
so he's not a great day you know and I
know that I knew that a year ago like if
it's debate she's gonna look better
every time little things that they do to
smooth out I mean she one thing she is
is she is a smooth [ __ ] man like
on these moments she keeps it cool yeah
but how about the psycho smile Jimmy was
that sending a chill appeal and she's
not yeah but she's smoother than oh yeah
she's just better at no she's in line
for 40 years professionally yeah yeah
and I'd like is my own thing I want
tax results I don't like that either I
mean is it the billionaire's are not for
guys like I know Hillary smile thing is
creepy like when he goes I go well you
know they're mistreating gays and she
just starts smiling like it's like we
left I've seen those videos I'm throwing
guys off the roof I've seen the ones the
Middle East is does it but they really
do they throw you off the [ __ ] roof
they did here in New York City be
raining men for three weeks Sam champion
comes on let's take a look at the
forecast outside Polly [ __ ] my light
part of cabbages oh by the way yes but
that doesn't get talked about right the
fact it does that was a great I was
gonna wash some point I was a great
point that he was drunk I think you
should give the money back
yeah and your timer Ted Cruz's mouth hop
in his mouth
it looks like an [ __ ] of teeth yeah
what doesn't have one of those but yeah
it was a you know whatever like I said I
judge them on a curb I did you know it's
a way to say yeah I'm for money talks I
definitely do to you what do you watch
when you're at home do you watch CNN
questionable of like mad about I flip
around you know I tried it but I'm a lot
of Fox
I watched mainly Fox News yeah because I
get both I really do I feel like I get
both sides that you know I mean I get to
see my friends on Fox that's why I wash
abet as when I know does it house right
yeah I know you see but the better TV to
Fox News like all the other news
networks don't know how to do a TV show
Greg Gutfeld made me a big Fox fan
because Greg I mean he's conservative
more so but he's a smart guy
and he's not like a language cop he's
not like uptight you know god you're
right he's a funny dude
he grow on me first I was like what's
with the unicorns and [ __ ] yeah and and
then but but then I saw making good
points on redeye here and there and then
he really stepped it up on the five I'm
like oh my god
yes way smarter than anybody Ramat what
you have a life and [ __ ] nahariya I
watched the five sometimes once in a
while I seen it I liked him but but but
God fell is like to me flying over their
head all of them yeah yeah
he doesn't mind getting mean Tina he's
not there to make friends no and he went
to Berkley so and you know so sometimes
a little bit of liberal [ __ ] sure
through but never what's his name I like
the guy to uh the the big Baba Oh Becca
I love Bob Beckel what was his last
outrageous statement you guys practicing
trouble for that
that was always an iron well he's a
heavy drinker - but is he so burly sober
bad yeah but fell off the wagon somebody
I don't know if that's true did he say
he said a couple months ago he said
something outrageous they do it while
he's on CNN Ursus yes we're on CNN uh
something about we should have them have
somebody whacked or killed who the [ __ ]
was it some beat you will you crack
staff we'll pull it up he wants snarled
that Julian Assange should be killed
yeah I thought it was a tit or was that
I wish I was on I would have said tell
us how you really feel I brought the
hash tag yeah I mean he was good like
when he was on the five he was good
every three weeks or so he was good for
saying something outrageous is Sam he
this is when I fell in love with Bekele
he was talking about hey Hannity had
some something said something really
conservative and I think he was on the
five he did this twice he goes he gave
the Italian [ __ ] you know that I'm tough
enough he acts you in buffin habla one
way that's not you see in Staten Island
with two Italians fight now on porch and
he goes buffing her which means [ __ ]
Naples whatever they set it on the air
and I told Colin about and the next
night he did it again so I think uh you
know and your favorite calm this was
amazing but Nick your favorite comic is
not a guy who politically was liking I
was like totally the polar opposite
you're talking about Michael Begley
absolutely yes but Mike is a very very
little kid he's a big big fan I love hex
yeah but every job takes forever almost
20 years
totally yeah all are opposites yeah but
I like his conviction in his dark poetry
when he was talking about Republicans
and [ __ ] and he backed it up with I like
his conviction he wasn't afraid to you
know uh but he was a smart guy and I
learned [ __ ] letlet you know about the
left listening to Higgs
how many comedians can you say that him
yeah him and Lisa Lampanelli and he
didn't come across as hypocritical he
wasn't lying he wasn't being
hypocritical he's being true right and
like if as long as somebody's being
honest and smart right like you know you
can you can even find common ground uh
Charlie in Delaware has a question for
Nick DiPaolo I wanted to get out of here
yes Charlie hi child what's going on
Charlie Zelle Krauthammer hey Nick uh
display during what
what was place but I like having Mitch
Hedberg is a neighbor back today all uh
well you heard the joke he did bad music
he's to come out of there I used to bang
on his wall this before I know it was
Mitch I moved into some you heard this
he no joke about me on Letterman I did
not know um yeah I moved into the shitty
apartment West Hollywood in the the day
I moved in a super tentacles hey there's
a committee or comedians a comedian
living next to you I go what's his name
he goes I don't know something head
burgers I'm I didn't even know Matt at
the time not too many people did I'm
like huh something like a few weeks
later hear like guitar coming out I got
this guy must be real [ __ ] heck I do
the walk but then I see him on let him
in a couple months later and I'm like
holy [ __ ]
I get the one of the funniest guys on
the planet living next to me but I used
to I used to bang his I don't if he was
in a band or his wife they would have
people and play like and I bang on the
wall and he wrote some joke about it
like you have to come around like I was
knocking on a door and um he did it on
Letterman
so remember Zoey used to book Thalia
Freeman yeah yeah I looked as a setlist
she she had a setlist on a napkin and it
second one it said to power oh and I'm
on it because I [ __ ] love that guy
and just is this yeah just a bit right
here knocking out walls probably oh wow
let's go two of them that's a special
anybody know who I am why did a bunch of
people who don't know who I am so am i
special
exactly I salute here in Los Angeles on
Sierra Bonita yep zip and I had a
neighbor and whenever he would knock on
my wall I knew he wanted me to turn my
music down that made me angry because I
like loud music so he knocked on the
wall I'd mess with his head I'd say go
around
I cannot open the wall I don't know if
you have a doorknob on the other side I
did over here there's nothing good it's
just flat
it's just what it's just flat mama
well as you know you see so many guys by
the way that have stolen Mitch's cadence
yeah yeah guys like @l and Mitch but the
post mimics mimicked yeah
unintentionally guys don't even know
they're doing it but you hear I think
those two of the most mimic can you
think anyone who gets mimicked as much
as those guys yes Jack Benny oh yeah I
could Tom I'm not saying Tom but Tom
Papa sounds like Jack Benny he's got
that nice hi yes yes friendly uh yeah
that cadence that I don't that I don't
have in me a podcast that's the that's
the funnest thing I do right it is yeah
if you I have a podcast you can hear for
free on iTunes riot cast calm on Mondays
if you like it you go to connect pal
uh.com slash Nick connect pal dot-com
slash Nick you can sign up for two to
three more shows a week for three
ninety-nine a month and it's growing
like it crazy it's one of the best
things to happen to me away there really
that that's smart to do the show for
free yeah give them a 22-week and then
if you like it you get three shows a
week yeah go to three more oh you do
extra shows that yes I do extra shows
and I said it's a buck a week for crisis
yeah and I put a lot of work I treat it
like a radio show I prep a couple hours
that I dunno play by yourself you just
talk just by myself that's great I got
to do and and you got you got experience
doing real radio so you really know how
to do I didn't when I first started
doing the podcast I'm like it's just
creepy I feel like a kid with a ham
radio in a basement didn't really like
it but then it started to grow on me and
and yeah it's the same muscle when I an
hour so yeah I do it's good right around
now everyday perfect not every day but
uh actually couple times a week connect
Palo a.com slash Nick if you want to
sign up or go to my website at Nick dip
calm